Disney's live-action snow white Under
Fire for replacing Seven Dwarfs with
quote magical creatures of all sizes and
genders and what do they do look at this
Freak Show
this you could have accomplished this by
going to Seattle and grabbing seven
heroin addicts that were living under a
[__] Bridge one guy said if somebody
had a problem I'm so curious oh this is
Peter Dinklage here's what Peter
Dinklage is doing he's taking the food
out of a little woke mouth of those
little mouse that could be eating Peter
Dinklage is stealing food out of their
mouth there's seven here's what Peter
Dinklage is saying I'm the only one that
can be famous just me sorry everybody
we're shutting that down you know how I
was a dwarf in Game of Thrones that's
cool everyone else were closing the
little Bridge the little bridge is going
up and no one can cross over it now